il arrive à titre de premier ministre et
ressort en tant que chef du parti
libéral incontournables visites pour
mettre un terme à la rumeur le pays est
officiellement en campagne électorale
les canadiens iront donc aux urnes le 20
septembre
justin trudeau se défend profiter de
sondages favorables pour obtenir une
majorité même en pleine pandémie même
devant la menace d'une quatrième vague
les choix que lui ont imposé la crise
sanitaire dit il doivent être approuvées
par les canadiens les canadiens méritent
de pouvoir se faire entendre de pouvoir
exprimer leur voix et leur choix sur
comment on va en finir avec cette
pandémie l'opposition conservatrice qui
dénonçait hier encore la nécessité d'une
élection n'a pas mis de temps à joindre
les hostilités il faut toujours avoir un
plan et un automne promet une approche
fraîche sur la gestion de la pandémie
est mis sur la création d'un million
d'emplois et l'équilibré budgétaire
d'ici dix ans pour se démarquer il y a
cinq parties mais deux choix
les conservateurs d'une côté où plus de
scandales plus de dépenser plus de
dettes de l'autre les québécoises et les
québécois
ont laissé comprendre assez clairement
qu'ils ne veulent pas d'une majorité
libérale le chef du bloc québécois lui
ne comprend pas pourquoi le parlement
est soudainement devenu dysfonctionnel
aux yeux de justin trudeau il promet de
livrer une chaude lutte au nom de la
défense des intérêts du québec il ya
même un risque
pour les gains que le québec aux faits
au cours des deux dernières années dans
le projet de majorité de monsieur
trudeau le npd qui a régulièrement faire
son appui aux libéraux ne voit pas non
plus pourquoi des élections sont
nécessaires maintenant jack meeting se
propose comme le défenseur des canadiens
plus vulnérables avec tes néo néo
démocrates vous avez quelqu'un qui ce
qui est de votre ba qui se bat pour vous
les libéraux font le pari qu'ils
bénéficieront d'un vent favorable grâce
à leur gestion de la pandémie mais il
souhaite aussi qu'une quatrième vague
alimentées par une flambée nouveau cap
pourrait rapidement venir assombrir
leur horizon électorale et si daniel
thibault radio canada ottawa